if you've done any research on Destiny's
somewhat tumultuous development then you
probably know that the planet closest to
the Sun Mercury was originally supposed
to play a much bigger role unfortunately
apart from trials of Osiris players
haven't really been able to set foot on
the planet but it sounds like that may
change destiny players who logged into
the game over the past weekend received
an emblem called rising light as well as
some strange coins and motes of light
Bungie advertised a small event as days
of the dawning several items in
Destiny's server have referenced the
dawning which is believed to be an
upcoming in-game event some fans believe
that this new emblem depicts Mercury's
architecture set against the backdrop of
a Rising Sun if this proves true then
players believe that this emblem and
other items that mention the dawning
could be linked to mercury in future
content considering how the planet may
have played a much bigger role earlier
in development this seems somewhat
plausible will hopefully know more soon
in the meantime though make sure to log
in to destiny so you can pick up those
free strange coins and motes of light
and for more on bungie share world
shooter keep yours a low supercells and
sleeper stimulant aimed at gamespot